one of the first things we saw after the
election was gun stocks just getting
absolutely smoked the two big ones in
the US are Smith and Wesson and Sturm
Ruger they sell about two and a quarter
million guns a year they were both down
about fifteen percent immediately the
morning after the election so this is
strange because Trump is the gun
candidate he was endorsed by the NRA you
would think it would be high times for
the gun Marquette the clinton's campaign
was very serious about gun control so
people that had considered buying a gun
were pushing those purchases up
now all of a sudden that fear vanishes
and people think market overall is going
to be a lot cooler the savvy executives
at these places are trying to take this
volatility out of their business they're
trying to diversify so Smith & Wesson in
the days leading up to the election
bought a company that makes survivalist
gear compasses knives machetes that kind
of thing they also change their name to
the entirely generic American outdoor
brands Corp just signaling to investors
and consumers that they're not just a
gun company that can be knocked off
course every 24 years